vous pensez que vous êtes un petit peu
une vedette maintenant non je pense pas
être une vodette je pense quand même
être une femme qui rend le bonheur à
beaucoup de
[Musique]
gens
les amis
caf8
program les soldats de la guerre oui les
soldats de la guerre ont fraternisé ont
rêvé un succès du front nos cœur à
l'Espérance à la foudre de nos
fronts je vais vous chanter Mimosette
elle 16S c'est ces personnes là qui
m'ont dit mais venez venez venez venez
réciter et moi j'étais tellement
heureuse de venir parce que ça donne la
joie de vivre tout ce qu'on voit tout ce
qu'on ressent peut le dire au moins ici
qu'ailleurs on ne veut pas c'est pour ça
que j'aime cette radio je voudrais
jamais qu'elle
cesse le grand patron de cette station
c'est un volcanique papi de 70 ans Félix
de polo alias Mario émigré italien mais
surtout poète et guitariste c'est en
France qu'il a découvert la liberté
d'expression et au moment de prendre sa
retraite il a proposé à sa femme Simone
de monter une radio l'émetteur installé
dans la cuisine émet 15h/ 24 avec le
soutien de
[Musique]
na
on de 80 82
83ie un chèque de 20 francs du Mario
1500 francs de pension voilà un chèque
de 20 francs pour la radio ça c'est la
valeur de ma radio vous pensez que vous
êtes un petit peu une vedette maintenant
non je pense pas être une vudette je
pense quand même est une femme qui rend
le bonheur à beaucoup de gens dans les
hôpitaux les foyers les personnes sol
tout
ça
enore de la France je trouvé inamissible
que aujourd'hui la bande FM l' encaparé
par les trouses financières avec la
publicité commerciale par
le et par le fasis
c'est toute ma
[Applaudissements]
journée vraiment n
parille
blané JIS
télé
ple je
fa il é d'attend vre
radio
blan les Ros blanch il est mort à
chantant les roses blanches avec Radi V
j'ai pleuré ça mar
[Musique]
voyz